I do care I care a lot and that's why I
fight back as long as I'm alive there'll
be more to say just finding out what
people's favorite thing is what they're
reacting to now my anger is very focused
I would like to leave a footprint I
think it's important to try everything
what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that can change the planet so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from three-time Grammy
Award winner pink and my take on her top
ten rules for success rule number four
is my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys liked the best
you've been very outspoken and I saw
unity with your daughter the VMAs I
thought it was it was just amazing
there's just always so much work to be
done and I talk about these things
because I've lived them I've been
through there hasn't been a day that has
gone by that someone hasn't said
something nasty about me
and it's not that it doesn't hurt me or
that I'm invincible or that I don't care
I do care I care a lot and that's why I
fight back what you feel is kind of the
next step for you and your career when
you've already achieved so much I think
I would like to be a country singer ya
know I don't know I still to this day
after all of that nonsense I still feel
like I have so much to prove to people
people still don't get it I'm always
gonna feel like a really popular
underdog people to this day so though
wow you can sing it's been like 13 years
of just singing so they're all there
will always be as long as I'm alive
there will be more to say I think I
don't know what that is exactly but as
long as my body can keep up with my mind
then I'll be alright my favorite part
about giving my baby not my willow but
my baby my other baby my album away is
just waiting for the feedback you know
from the fans on the website and just
from friends and different people well
most of my friends I have to like give
them an album and then let them know I
put it out because they don't really
care but just finding out what people's
favorite thing is what they're reacting
to and what the feedback let me ask you
something as somebody who's a who makes
their living as a performer as an artist
as a as a singer as a songwriter and all
that what do you want to get out of this
whole thing look what do you want out of
this well I kinda already did all the
things I said I was gonna do when I was
a little girl be famous piss people off
use them in a real tree now I used to be
angry at the world now my anger is very
focused I would like to leave a
footprint and and if I can help inspire
other people to be individuals and stand
up for what they believe in and be who
they are then I did my job
and sometimes inspiration is is what is
the most important thing is what we need
to get moving and our country needs to
get moving
I think the reason why I have such an
authentic relationship with I don't even
like the word fans but with people is
because I am being honest and I am being
vulnerable and I am talking about real
life and my real life and kind of
wearing all my flaws visibly so it's
it's helped me feel less alone you start
working with for a little time with this
VanSickle basic instincts and choice
right yeah what could it be like the
biggest lesson of that time I'm a
chameleon I think it's important to I
mean I trained classically I sang in
gospel in all black churches and I had a
punk band I think it's important to try
everything and I don't I mean I play
drums but my voice is my instrument so
it's important to use it in every way
that you can to get better you know and
don't be narrow-minded and that's what
being indifferent I mean basic instinct
I was a token white girl and choice was
this white R&B group and you know it's
just a lot of different things it was
really good for my resume the way that
you walk on that stage is the outcome
you're gonna get I'm gonna have had
shows back-to-back shows in the same
place same lineup almost basically the
same audience and the first night I've
walked on feeling insecure and I've had
the war show of my life and it's all in
here and then the second day I'm like
we'll screw that I don't wanna do that
again what's the worst that can happen
it can't be worse than that
and I go on not caring as much and I
have the best show of my life so it's
just a it's a head game so you kind of
just my dad tells me to throw my head
back spit in the wind and show them what
I got so that's what I do I have always
said that pain and frustration and anger
sadness it's all just motivation to
write I think when I'm happy I'm useless
I mean I just think the best work comes
from heartbreak or devastation or loss
or insanity
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you all saw pigs performance at the
Grammys I mean literally I was just
saying the audience I had to get closer
to my TV to see what was actually
happening that was a jaw-dropping
ceiling hanging almost naked ripped
bodies situation all I can say is Wow II
kazowie everybody all over the world
next day was like did you see that
did you see that it was fun I was a good
night for me was it a good night that
was one of my first questions to you
because all of us have in our lives
you know momentous occasions like a
moment of your life that one of the
greatest moments of your do you think
that will always be I think so I think
so for me it was it was when everyone
stood up at the end that came down just
I know my silks and I was working it and
I and then I let the silks go and
everyone stood up and I went from super
graceful to like it felt transcendent it
felt like taking us out of something
more than just the music but into the
music and I wanted to get all the famous
people wet I remember seeing pink at
Brixton Academy and I was it was
misunderstood record so I was about 13
or 14 and I'd never heard live like
being in the in the room of someone I'd
never heard someone sing like that live
I mean because I was in before that I
was into the Spice Girls and stuff like
that and they can't sing obviously you
know I know that now I remember sort of
feeling our cars in a wind tunnel and
her voice just hitting me and I mean I
was just it was incredible I mean it was
beyond anything and that record is
incredible anyway but it was my first
experience of like thinking I mean I so
fast
I'm singing oh joy I mean that live you
know because I you know the singers
before that was like James and I've
never seen them not live I was at the
Grammys in 2010
painted this stunning rendition of her
ballad glitter in the air the
performance is one of the most
physically courageous and beautiful
things that I've ever witnessed but
there is this one moment when she was
lowered into the water and then lifted
back up of the whole audience and she's
really like just gushing water all over
these suddenly scrambling uber serious
VIPs down below and I remember watching
this and thinking that this is the most
badass
punk-rock thing that I've ever seen in
music there's so me when it
about yourself
[Music]
you're wrong
change the voices
[Music]
make some love
[Music]
so complicated
the Cameo
you
with so much hatred such a tired game
I can fake shakes down
[Applause]
pretty
thank you
pretty-pretty
don't you ever
thank you
Hey
the whole world scared so I swallow the
meat and the only thing I should be
drinking is an ice-cold beer the pool in
line
we tried tried try we try so hot so
waste of my time looking for the critics
cuz that everywhere they don't like my
jeans they don't get my hair exchanged
ourselves we do it all the time why do I
do that why do we do that yeah
to me
pretty pretty please
don't you ever feel
like you're nothing you are perfect to
me
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because mr. Lucas
Despero asked me to if there's someone
you'd like to vote on for the next top
ten check out the link in the
description and go and have your say
finally you want to give a quick shout
of - Stefanie Noel Stefanie thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and tweeting about it I
really appreciate the support and I'm so
glad that you enjoyed the book so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
I'm always trying to be better whether
it's performance or songwriting
I think vocally I'm a lot better because
I don't smoke anymore so I'm just trying
to not repeat myself and try to evolve
and try to just get better find a quiet
inner strength and hold on to it life
can be fabulous if you stick it out and
I know that seems impossible sometimes
when you're young but I was just there I
feel like yesterday I was 13 hating my
life contemplating suicide and I found a
passion and a hobby and I pursued it
with blinders and anyone that didn't
like it could kiss my entire ass and
they still can so take my strength take
my heart take everyone in here strength
and just keep the fight alive keep going